41 years young
and that is rich hill and with the mets
nine games eight starts overall this
season he is six and six and the
curveball bends in for strike three call
they're going to see a lot of quality
curve balls tonight from hill and wayne
wright and that's the first one and it
gets hill to strikeout to start the
night her ball hit the other way and the
lines are able to smother it he picked
it out of the air they say and that's
the second half three two coming and the
curveball misses outside so on the 11th
pitch o'neal who was down in the counter
and two works out a two on one
drives this one out to left should be
playable for mcneal
and at the edge of the track he makes
the catch to retire the side
adam wainwright eight in one and a one
eight six era and leading major league
baseball in innings since july 21st only
aureus of the dodgers has more wins
slapped over the bag that's a base hit
for vr chased by o'neal
the art takes the turn and holds on
so an opposite field single for vr to
start at the bottom of the first
fly ball to tyler o'neill and left
and the first out here in the home after
the first and it brings in conforto
conforto hits a ground ball to the
second baseman edmund bobble that picks
it up underhands to first to get
conforto tommy was trying to get his
body in position with his back to second
base to field the ball and make a throw
to second to get vr but the ball popped
in and out of the glove so he took the
sure out at first
off the plate first walk issued by wayne
oh and it's outside ball four and that
loads them up for mcneal so back to
about two out walks from wainwright the
o2 pitch
curveball and he struck him out and the
match strand of bases loaded molina is
six for his last 19. he'll lead it off
in the second inning
and yada rips it out to left that's down
into the corner
and with that molina trots into second
base yada year molina with the double
and that's now 399
doubles runner on second nobody out
dylan carlson the rookie right fielder
just 22 years old
curveball lifted out two left center
that ball is down molina will score
dylan carlson on his way to second and
it's a one-nothing st louis lead carlson
drives in his 50th one-nothing st louis
good piece of hitting right here didn't
have to hit it hard just hit it where
they ain't
there is no one out there
one two coming
and on the ground to third vr checks the
runner
and gets the out sosa retired for the
first out of the second vader pops one
up on the left side
and door back pedals a couple of strides
that comes in
two up
curve ball pulled down to third vr will
go across the diamond to get wayne right
and that retires the side back-to-back
doubles by molina and carlson produced
the first run here's kevin pilar
there's sosa to his left and hits the
umpire oh goodness
sosa hit the umpire on the side of the
face
oh my goodness
it's junior valentine spinning here
obviously a little bit off balance and
you can see he didn't even have his
head looked uh over on the right side he
was getting ready for
the play at first
no he never saw it coming
i mean i've never seen anything i'm so
happy that he's smiling wow way out wow
so top of the order for the cardinals
and tommy edmund edmund struck out
looking against hill the first time get
hard down the left field line if it
stays fair it's a double it's up against
the wall edmond heading to second base
he slides in safely a leadoff double and
that is a double number 38 for tommy
edmond now paul goldschmidt will stand
in another fabulous year that
goldschmidt is having up the middle base
hit tommy edmond will score and it's two
to nothing st louis
goldie drives in his 83rd two-nothing
redbirds
job right here jumping on the first
fastball especially with runners in
scoring position
cardinal first baseman paul goldschmidt
one for two
goldschmidt with a drive
left field at the wall gone
goldschmidt home run number 25.
he's driven in two
and the cardinals have a three nothing
lead he unloaded to left center field on
a 1-1 pitch
25 home runs 83 runs batted in 2-2
coming to mccann
curveball lined and caught by sosa
outstanding play emundo social short
takes a hit away from mccann
thank you
sosa for making that play as adam would
be saying right now
so now dom will pinch it he struck out
as a pinch hitter last night
and down the line's in at the left
center for a base hit
vader trying to track it down in the gap
dom trying for two and he makes it
safely with a one-out double
hit to short sosa and a hop
[Applause]
throws out vr two out
and the curveball misses for ball four
so lenore is on
[Music]
grounded into the glove of goldie he
steps on the bag
bueno and the cardinals
get through five unscathed well here's
pete alonso number 20 walks up to home
plate
look at that frozen with the breaking
ball and a strikeout of pete alonso his
third tonight he got him and the ball
gets away from molina baez will make it
to first
a strikeout and that's the second one
that's gotten through molina tonight
and there's your ground ball edmond
only play though to get the out at first
and there's two away
yeah the curveball and
the fly ball into the glove of tyler
o'neill wayne right through his sixth
scoreless he's got a three-nothing lead
t.j mcfarland the new pitcher chevy call
to the pin
he'll get mccann
a pinch hitter and vr
ground ball left side arenado
makes the play low throw dug out by
goldie and that's the first out
and a ground ball base hit one out hit
off the bench for davis top of the
lineup and jonathan vr the switch hitter
who is one for three
caught by edmond and it's a double play
tommy edmond catches the liner and turns
two in a key spot in this game and now
alex reyes in the face lindork and porto
and alonso
there's ball four and so lenore is off
for the third time tonight a lead off
block to strap the bottom of the eighth
hole the hole in a base hit just past
goldschmidt lindor will go first to
third and the mets will get alonzo to
the plate as the tying run
he got him nasty pitch in a strikeout of
alonso
boy that's a good pitch there i'll tell
you what first out here in the eighth
and now it's baez
check swing and he went strikeout of
baez back-to-back case and reyes won out
away the one-two pitch by alex reyes got
him
strikes out the side in the eighth
and the cardinals looking to add on at
first and third of the one out the one-o
or renato
into shallow right may drop and it does
a run will score
everybody safe and the cardinals have
extended their lead for nothing orinato
now has driven in 97 on the year
molina base heading to left here comes
tyler o'neal the wave of men the throw
to the plate is cut off and how about
this base running here that's a rundown
coming up and yaddy's going to wind up
in second with no throw
bases loaded one down here's sosa
sosa base hit
one run in
to extend the cardinal lead the bases
remain loaded
and st louis has opened up a six nothing
lead here in the ninth inning harrison
bader do up sacks full still one out
by the way that's a base hit into right
field
another run will score
vader comes through with the bases
loaded carlson back to the bag at third
and that makes it a seven nothing st
louis lead they remain loaded
cody whitley is the new pitcher the
cardinals one out away from taking game
one
strikes out the side here in the ninth
reyes
struck out the side in the eighth
whitley follows in the ninth and the
cardinals win it by the final of seven
to nothing
and it's win number 74.